it's time for drew's news your good news
bridge over troubled waters and with me
at the desk the simon to my garfunkel
dressy husband hi everybody
hi
hi drew
hi rossi
love you love you
oh and i'm really excited because today
we are joined by an incredible guest she
is a drag race icon
actor and you can currently catch her on
the emmy nominated hbo show we're here
where she travels all across
small town america to make drag dreams
come true
but it's just so full of humanity i am
so excited ladies and gentlemen hi
please welcome cj pierce
better known as chandela
hello oh my god i mean you're so famous
it's so wonderful that you would take
the time to come by
uh rossie and i's news desk excuse me
did she just call me this is drew
barrymore and ross matthews hallelujah
i'm very excited to be here well if you
say your name i mean it a lot of people
speak up people really love you you have
garnered a lot of loyalty and fandom
over the years and a tremendous amount
of respect you are huge and very very
loved in your field oh thank you you
know what i'm very grateful for all the
love and thank you so much it's just i
was shown love in my family in um in my
town and growing up and so i feel that
everyone deserves to feel that and
that's why i love to share love with
people well that's a perfect transition
to your show which i cannot recommend
more it's called we're here it's on hbo
max it's been emmy nominated i saw the
first episode uh basically the pilot
and what you need to know about this
show as far as i'm concerned is it's a
lot of what i'd like to accomplish here
on our show
it doesn't wrap everything up in a bow
it's allowing to
have people be who they are feel the way
they feel
and there's an honesty um about the show
that is so authentic well it's a
docu-series and everything that people
have been going through in their lives
in their real lives we are have the
opportunity to give them an
amplification a microphone a camera to
share that story and we don't cut
anything out that is not real and
authentic because let me tell you
something when people see the show
they sometimes say i cried or i laughed
or i connected with it you don't have to
be gay or queer to watch we're here and
really connect with it because it is
real yeah it is real and sometimes
people pull a real connection from this
and like being here with you it's just
brilliant so thank you so much
all right let's get into some headlines
okay well first um ross you're up an
outfielder for the atlanta braves has
been showing up to work with a fabulous
accessory suddenly i'm into baseball gq
this player his name is jock which is
not a joke jack peterson has been
playing in the field wearing pearls yeah
jock says they're 100 real pearls and
there's no big story behind him he's
just a fan of pearls uh you know men
have been doing this we've seen a lot of
them in pearls shawn mendes
asap rocky usher
harry styles they look they've all been
wearing pearls uh i will say this is the
first athlete i've seen wearing them and
i think
this is what baseball needed just a
little more
accessorizing angela thoughts
listen i think that mr jock should be
able to allow be allowed and supported
in what he wants to wear yeah fashion is
about your own freedom and your
expression it does not like denote what
kind of gender identity or sexual
preference you have it's a set of pearls
let the man wear the pearls the question
is did he catch the ball yes thank you
they do that in baseball right they
teach you that's the one here
that is a good point
i actually have a picture i went with my
ex-boyfriend to a premiere
um and yeah that's my ex-boyfriend eric
erlinson he's the sweetest person on
planet earth um but he's wearing a pearl
necklace do you remember when he put the
pearls on were you like cute or you're
like those are pearls um i was like that
is so hot yeah and look it's like
machine gun kelly you know he's wearing
the pearls today it's full circle i
think a man in a strand of pearls is
super cool harry styles doesn't like
everybody worships harry styles right
yeah i mean
i'm totally
into this but it's true i've never seen
it on a more manly man
on a baseball diamond and you know it's
amazing to see us breaking down gender
stereotypes because that's what we have
we have this idea of what a man can wear
and what a woman can wear and what you
can
we just need to break that down and
allow people to be people i'm so happy
to be able to express myself and drag i
have a wig on i know you thought it was
real i have a wig it doesn't look like
that but you know it's about your
expression of yourself it doesn't mean
anything it shouldn't be looked down
upon in any way
yeah preach that's it
cheers to you and you want to take the
next story oh yes indeed okay now this
one is good speaking of pearls that
happens to be the name of a very famous
skeleton coming from my own hometown of
paris texas
get into this
over on a local news site called my
paris texas there is a skeleton actually
a lady who's not a skeleton a lady named
melissa baker okay and she's gotten
recently very locally famous for taking
two of her skeletons you know that she's
decorating with and having them posed in
different positions in her yard and her
window people are loving this they're
doing camping the skeletons are camping
they are washing their little skeleton
dogs together are they talking yoga yes
they are doing poses yes oh that is the
downward facing fibula
i love this i love this story i love
that she's doing that that's what i'm so
happy yeah well i see i love that you
are happy because i think that anyone in
paris texas that can get some extra
shine by just being creative baby do you
and she i probably went to high school
with this young lady i don't need to
look at my facebook yeah right i bet you
know her i could it's small melissa
baker shangela call me
that's great
now
you say you're from paris texas but i
know shangela during the pandemic and
lockdown you actually stopped performing
and went home to paris to stay with your
family what was that like oh you know
what if there was ever a silver lining
to something as
hard and difficult that the world's been
going through like the pandemic it would
be the amount of time that i was able to
go and spend with my mom and my grandma
my little nieces and nephew my cousins
my aunt everybody because i've been on
the road for like the past decade just
traveling i've performed on every
continent except antarctica and i got a
happy feet number gonna take down there
but um
it's really great to be able to spend
time and i never knew you know my
grandma's 83 she's in a wheelchair she
had never seen me in drag in person
before and i was getting in drag to like
make cameo videos or you know do zooms
and she said oh you look just like tina
turner
thanks grant and then one time she told
me i look like a white woman
my foundation was a little light i guess
but it was so much it was so great it's
been so great for our relationship to be
so close together i got to do her makeup
you know we play around and just
recently and my college alma mater she
came and surprised me and watched me
perform for the very first time
and it's just a really beautiful
moment to be able to have with my family
and be a part of it and that's one thing
that this pause on life really helped me
to do is to reconnect with my family and
in our show like we're here we travel
around a lot of people don't have that
support from their birth family and i'm
very grateful to do that and i try to
share them with the world and and tell
everybody what you call your grandma oh
that's grangela yeah
yeah
hi graham
oh i'm so happy for you and thank you
for sharing that i was completely
wrapped in that story i just love that
so much oh thank you um you know our
last story we've got this tick-tock um
wellness trend it's totally free and
it's easy to do
it's all the rage the hot girl walk yeah
the website toast reports that the
hashtag hot girl walk has over 5.9
million views and the concept is
credited to a tick-tocker named mia and
the concept is simple go for an
hour-long walk every single day and
focus your thoughts on just three areas
number one things you're grateful for
and number two things you want to
achieve
and number three how crazy hot you are
oh yes that one just the empowering
message to yourself and shangela i mean
i would love to learn a hot girl walk
from none other than you would you teach
us how to do it what baby if y'all want
the walk let's go let's go come on
okay ready come on
come on
okay
okay
[Applause]
okay but generally you can take the all
the walking you want all right this is
like an airline in the middle of it yeah
exactly the runway that's right but you
want to the hot girl walk is all about
your positive affirmations so you get
that step come on get the step in get a
step come on here yeah there i go diva
come on oh rush oh my god
there you go now you're walking and you
say to yourself i am fabulous i am
fabulous i turn the party i turn the
party i love myself i love myself every
room i walk in i'm going to make a
change every room i walk in i'm going to
make a chain sunshine sunshine fruit
roll-ups roll-ups i don't know those
things make me happy
and you and then you stop because i
don't know how those the girls do their
hot girl walk but i have to stop
sometimes they just go oh yes i'm
feeling it
oh yes i'm feeling it
[Applause]
one of my favorite shows debuts monday
nights at 9pm on hbo and you can stream
it
for everyone
they include everyone
[Music]